Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply.
您的夏天从家得宝（Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销活动开始。是时候用下一款烧烤架——四头燃气烧烤架来开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需199美元。整个季节都可以用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅来招待亲友，仅需49美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为5月14日至5月27日。仅限美国，受条款限制。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Have you ever done a job interview where you're asked, what's your biggest weakness? And did you answer? Oh, I'm such a perfectionist. There's a good reason this answer has become a job interview cliche. Perfection, after all, is usually seen as a selling point, an asset disguised as a flaw.
详情请见HomeDepot.com的差价补偿页面。您是否曾参加过面试，被问到“你最大的缺点是什么”？您当时是怎么回答的？“哦，我是一个完美主义者。”这个答案成为面试陈词滥调是有充分理由的。毕竟，完美通常被视为一个卖点，一种伪装成缺点的资产。
Who wouldn't want to hire a perfect employee, after all? But psychologist's research suggests that perfectionism may not be something to aspire to at all. In recent years, researchers have found rising rates of perfection, perfectionism in the United States and around the world, and they've begun to recognize the toll that the drive to be perfect can take on people's mental health and well-being. So why do more and more of us feel the need to push ourselves to perfection? Does our achievement culture demand it? Is it social media and the endless comparisons that come with it? And what does it mean to be a perfectionist anyway? How is perfectionism different from just striving for excellence? And what can we do as individuals,
毕竟，谁不想雇佣一个完美的员工呢？但心理学家的研究表明，完美主义可能根本不值得追求。近年来，研究人员发现美国乃至全球的完美主义比例都在上升，他们也开始意识到追求完美对人们心理健康和幸福感造成的损害。那么，为什么我们越来越多的人感到需要把自己推向完美？是我们的成就文化要求的吗？是社交媒体及其带来的无休止的攀比吗？到底什么是完美主义者？完美主义与追求卓越有什么不同？作为个人，我们能做些什么，
as parents, as a society, to help ourselves and each other recognize that often, good, is good enough. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Thomas Curran, an associate professor in the Department of Psychological and Behavioral Science at the London School of Economics. He's a leading expert on perfection in and how perfectionism is increasing in the modern world. His popular TED talk on perfectionism has been viewed more than three million times, and his research has been covered by news outlets, including the New York Times,
作为父母，作为一个社会，我们能做些什么来帮助自己和彼此认识到，通常情况下，“足够好”就已经很好了。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是伦敦政治经济学院心理与行为科学系的副教授托马斯·柯伦（Thomas Curran）博士。他是研究完美主义的顶尖专家，也是研究完美主义在现代世界中如何增长的权威。他关于完美主义的TED演讲观看次数已超过三百万次，他的研究也被《纽约时报》、
the Wall Street Journal, NPR, and CNN.com. His debut book is The Perfection Trap, Embracing the Power of Good Enough. Dr. Curran, thank you for joining me today. Pleasure to be speaking of a recap. Back in 2019, you published a study that found rising rates, to perfectionism and young people in the US, Canada, and the UK over the past several decades. Tell us about that work. What kind of data did you look at? What did you find? Yeah, that was the, I suppose, my biggest paper I've ever published. And I didn't realize
《华尔街日报》、美国国家公共电台（NPR）和CNN.com等新闻媒体报道。他的处女作是《完美陷阱：拥抱“足够好”的力量》（The Perfection Trap, Embracing the Power of Good Enough）。柯伦博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。很高兴能参加这次谈话。回顾2019年，您发表了一项研究，发现过去几十年来，美国、加拿大和英国年轻人的完美主义比例在上升。请给我们介绍一下这项工作。您查看了什么样的数据？您发现了什么？是的，那应该是我发表过的最重要的论文。我当时并没有意识到
at the time it was going to be quite the story it was. It was really a hunch. Sometimes the best ideas are the simplest ideas. And I just had a hunch of seeing young people in my office. I'm a professor. So I work with young people a lot. And it became evident to me over the recent years, that there was a lot of pressure that young people were putting on themselves, they were feeling that they weren't good enough or that no matter how hard they tried, they weren't achieving in the ways in which they were hoping to achieve. And I was seeing a lot of requests for not just academic support, but also mental health support as well.
它会产生如此大的影响。这其实是一个直觉。有时最好的想法往往是最简单的想法。我只是在办公室里看到年轻人时产生了一种直觉。我是一名教授，所以我经常与年轻人打交道。近年来，我明显感觉到年轻人给自己施加了很大的压力，他们觉得如果自己不够好，或者无论怎么努力，都无法达到他们期望的成就。我看到很多不仅是学术支持，还有心理健康支持的需求。
And all of this seemed to be bound up in this idea of self-imposed pressure. So one of the things I decided to do was to try to understand if there is a trend. here, if something's happening, something in the water around young people, whether we can maybe detect any of those changes in levels of perfectionism. So that was the hunch and Clay did all the possible information that could possibly clay on levels of perfectionism in college students from the US, UK, Canada, starting in around 1989, so late 80s, and all the way through to around 2021, 2022. And because college students have broadly similar characteristics, which is, by the way, terrible thing for sampling generally in psychology, but it does happen to have an advantage
所有这些似乎都与这种自我施加的压力有关。所以我决定做的一件事是尝试了解这里是否存在一种趋势，是否有什么事情正在发生，年轻人周围的环境是否发生了变化，我们是否能检测到完美主义水平的任何变化。这就是我的直觉，我收集了所有可能关于美国、英国、加拿大大学生完美主义水平的信息，从1989年左右，也就是80年代末开始，一直到2021年、2022年左右。因为大学生具有大致相似的特征，顺便说一下，这对心理学抽样来说通常是一件糟糕的事情，但它确实有一个优势，
when it comes to comparing across generations because they're broadly similar, can make reliable comparisons. And if you string them out over time, you see rising levels of perfectionism among young people, and that hunch was confirmed in the data, and those rises were quite steep, particularly for what's called socially prescribed perfectionism, which is a sense that other people and everyone around me expects me to be perfect. That was rising exponentially at a rate of about 33% increase since the late 80s. So, yeah, some really interesting and challenging findings.
那就是在进行跨代比较时，因为他们大致相似，可以进行可靠的比较。如果你把这些数据按时间串联起来，你会看到年轻人中完美主义水平在上升，这种直觉在数据中得到了证实，而且上升幅度相当大，特别是对于所谓的“社会规定型完美主义”，即一种认为其他人以及我周围的每个人都期望我完美的心理。自80年代末以来，这一比例以约33%的速度呈指数级增长。所以，是的，这确实是一些非常有趣且具有挑战性的发现。
And that propelled me, I suppose, into the TED Talk sphere and writing a book and all the rest of it because people really wanted to know about this phenomenon. Well, how do researchers measure perfectionism? Was there some kind of scale that you used or did you have to create one? Yeah, so luckily there is a scale that most researchers use when they study perfectionism is called the multi-dimensional perfectionism scale. It was developed by two psychologists, Paul Hewitt, Canadian psychologist, Paul Hewitt, and Gordon Flett. I think Gordon Fletts been on the podcast previously. Incredible scholars did a lot of heavy lifting in this area, developed the scale, and that's what we've been using across the years.
这推动我进入了TED演讲领域，写了一本书等等，因为人们真的很想了解这种现象。那么，研究人员是如何衡量完美主义的呢？你们使用某种量表吗，还是必须自己创建一个？是的，幸运的是，大多数研究人员在研究完美主义时使用一种量表，叫做“多维完美主义量表”。它是由两位心理学家开发的，加拿大心理学家保罗·休伊特（Paul Hewitt）和戈登·弗莱特（Gordon Flett）。我想戈登·弗莱特之前也上过这个播客。他们是了不起的学者，在这个领域做了大量艰苦的工作，开发了这个量表，这就是我们多年来一直在使用的工具。
And that's amazing because we've got one consistent tool there. It's a paper and pencil questionnaire that measures socially corrects of perfectionism, as I mentioned, but also some of self-oriented perfectionism, which is perfectionism comes from within high self-standers and excessive self-standers. And, yeah, students have responded to this same survey now for about 30, 35 of years. So that gives us a treasure trove of data really to make these cohort, do these cohort analyses, and that's what we've used to derive our conclusions from. What are a couple of the questions, just so our listeners can understand what you ask people,
这太棒了，因为我们有一个一致的工具。这是一份纸笔问卷，衡量我提到的社会规定型完美主义，也衡量一些“自我导向型完美主义”，即源于内在的高自我标准和过高的自我要求。是的，学生们现在已经对这份同样的调查问卷做出了大约30到35年的回应。所以这确实为我们提供了宝贵的数据宝库来进行这些队列分析，这就是我们得出结论的依据。能不能举几个例子，让我们的听众了解一下你们问人们的问题，
that indicates that, yeah, you're a perfectionist. So self-oriented perfectionism is a form of perfectionism that comes from inside of us. it's high self-set goals and expectations. And we might use an item like, I expect myself to be perfect or everything I do has to be perfect. And we might measure that on a one to five like at scale. So if you don't agree with that statement, then I don't agree with that statement. So it might be a one.
这表明“是的，你是一个完美主义者”。自我导向型完美主义是一种源于我们内心的完美主义形式。它表现为高自我设定的目标和期望。我们可能会使用这样的题目：“我期望自己是完美的”或“我做的每一件事都必须是完美的”。我们可能会在1到5分的李克特量表上衡量这一点。所以如果你不同意这个陈述，那么我就不同意这个陈述。所以它可能是1分。
If you really agree with that statement and strongly agree, you would put a five and everywhere in between. These infectious constructs, they really operate on a spectrum. So higher or lower, most people are in the middle. And that middle bit is increasing over time, as we saw in our data. socially described affections with another form of affections that we measure. And that's really rooted in pressures from the outside world. So the people who expect me to be perfect, my parents expect me to be perfect.
如果你非常同意这个陈述，你会选5分，中间的任何分值都可以。这些完美主义结构确实是在一个光谱上运作的。所以有高有低，大多数人在中间。正如我们在数据中看到的那样，中间部分随着时间的推移在增加。社会规定型完美主义是我们衡量的另一种完美主义形式。这确实植根于来自外部世界的压力。所以那些期望我完美的人，比如我的父母期望我完美。
For example, those are sorts of things we might ask and measure of social to perfectionism. And again, same principle. If you disagree, it's a one. If you agree, it's a five and everywhere in between. And once you aggregate those to items, get an average, you can get a reasonably good idea of where you sit on the spectrum. Now, you've talked about different,
例如，这些是我们可能会问到的关于社会规定型完美主义的问题。同样，原则是一样的。如果你不同意，就是1分。如果你同意，就是5分，中间的任何分值都可以。一旦你汇总了这些题目，取一个平均值，你就能对自己在光谱上的位置有一个相当好的了解。现在，你谈到了不同，
kinds of perfectionism. He said self-oriented, there's other-oriented and socially prescribed. Have all of these been increasing? Yes. It's important to bear in mind that when it comes to self-oriented perfectionism, that started from a high baseline. So in the late 80s, it was already quite high. It's a five-point light at scale. It was around four the mean scores across many, many samples of college students. So that already started high. It went even higher over time. But what was really interesting is not necessarily the self-worn infections, although that wasn't interesting finding, but what was going on was socially prescribed as really interesting, because that didn't start very high. That started around three, right? So around the midpoint scale,
种类的完美主义。你说有自我导向型、他人导向型和社会规定型。所有这些都在增加吗？是的。重要的是要记住，当谈到自我导向型完美主义时，它从一个很高的基线开始。所以在80年代末，它已经相当高了。这是一个5分制的李克特量表。在许多大学生的样本中，平均分在4分左右。所以它一开始就很高。随着时间的推移，它变得更高了。但真正有趣的不一定是自我导向型完美主义，尽管那也是一个有趣的发现，真正有趣的是社会规定型完美主义，因为它一开始并不高。它大约在3分左右，对吧？也就是量表的中间点，
basically, most people said, yeah, kind of, kind of not to those items. However, we're seeing that now sharply accelerated. We've updated our 2009 paper with new data when we're seeing a sharp acceleration in recent years for socially prescribed pressures. And that's really worrying because it's those social pressures that most concern us when it comes to things like mental health. They have the strongest link with depression, anxiety, worry, rumination. And so that's what it concerns us because what we used to see perhaps in the past was high strivings or high self-oriented perfectionism, but kind of moderate levels of socially prescribed perfectionism, but now what we're seeing is a slightly different pattern in recent generations
基本上，大多数人对这些题目说“还可以，或者不太确定”。然而，我们看到它现在急剧加速。我们用新的数据更新了我们2009年的论文，我们看到近年来社会规定型压力急剧加速。这确实令人担忧，因为当我们谈到心理健康问题时，这些社会压力最让我们担心。它们与抑郁、焦虑、担忧、反刍思维的联系最强。所以这就是让我们担心的地方，因为我们过去看到的可能是高追求或高自我导向型完美主义，但社会规定型完美主义水平适中，但现在我们看到的是最近几代人中略有不同的模式，
where they've got high self-oriented perfectionism, but fast accelerating socially prescribed perfectionism. What do you think is driving these increases? I mean, what's changed in our society in the last couple of decades that would lead to this rise in perfectionism? That's the whole book in and of itself. I mean, first of all, it's not a causal analysis. So essentially, anything I say here would be speculative. But nevertheless, we can say with reasonable confidence that there are a number of factors,
他们有很高的自我导向型完美主义，但社会规定型完美主义在快速加速。你认为是什么在推动这些增长？我的意思是，过去几十年来我们的社会发生了什么变化，导致了完美主义的这种上升？这整本书都在讨论这个问题。我的意思是，首先，这不是一个因果分析。所以本质上，我在这里说的任何话都是推测性的。但尽管如此，我们可以相当有把握地说，有许多因素，
and one of which we have empirically tested. So one of the things we think is happening is parental behavior. are changing, the way in which we rear children is changing. There's a lot more pressure, a lot more surveillance, a lot more monitoring of young people for good reason, and also a lot more expectation as well. It's been placed on young people, particularly in the academic sphere, and there's a lot of evidence to support those claims. But we've shown empirically that young people are perceiving that the parents are demanding
其中一个我们已经进行了实证检验。所以我们认为正在发生的事情之一是父母行为的改变，我们抚养孩子的方式正在改变。有更多的压力，更多的监视，更多对年轻人的监控，这是有充分理由的，也有更多的期望。年轻人身上被寄予了更多期望，特别是在学术领域，有很多证据支持这些说法。但我们已经从实证上证明，年轻人感觉到父母在要求
more of them, particularly in the academic route. And those higher demands, those higher expectations are highly correlated with perfectionism. So you put those two things together and you begin to see that changing parental practices towards more expectant and controlling forms of rearing have a direct correlation with perfectionism. And that may be one of the reasons why perfectionism is rising among young people. But there are factors way beyond parents. And it's also important to recognize that this isn't something that parents are doing intentionally. They're just responding to pressures in the outside world, right? I mean, ID League acceptance rates are around 5% today.
他们更多，特别是在学术道路上。而那些更高的要求、更高的期望与完美主义高度相关。所以你把这两件事放在一起，你就会开始看到，改变父母的教养方式，使其变得更加苛求和控制，与完美主义有直接的相关性。这可能是完美主义在年轻人中上升的原因之一。但还有远超父母的因素。同样重要的是要认识到，这不是父母故意在做的事情。他们只是在回应外部世界的压力，对吧？我的意思是，常春藤盟校的录取率今天在5%左右，
they were 10% in 2014. That is an incredible amount of pressure that parents see, they feel, and they're going to naturally translate the counter to their kids in terms of higher academic expectation because they know it's even harder to get into the elite colleges. And elite college education is really important if you want to get into the elite professions. So parents just responding to wider pressures that are going on in the wider environment, and that isn't just in schools or colleges when it comes to standardized, testing and more stringent entry criteria.
2014年是10%。父母看到、感受到了难以置信的压力，他们自然会把这种压力转化为对孩子更高的学术期望，因为他们知道进入精英大学变得更难了。如果你想进入精英职业，精英大学教育确实很重要。所以父母只是在回应更广泛的环境压力，这不仅仅是在学校或大学里，当涉及到标准化考试和更严格的入学标准时。
It's also the broader economy. We've slowed down and that means less opportunities for young people, particularly in the workplace. That's an added pressure that young people feel and also parents feel. So again, that ratches up the pressure. And there, of course, are of a factor, social media among them that has come on the scene in the last 10 years. That certainly hasn't helped when it's come to those social pressures and those idealized
这也是更广泛的经济环境。我们放慢了脚步，这意味着年轻人的机会减少了，特别是在工作场所。这是年轻人和父母都感受到的额外压力。所以，这再次加剧了压力。当然，还有其他因素，包括过去10年出现的社交媒体。当涉及到那些社会压力和那些理想化的
images of how we should be looking and appearing and paving. There's so many factors that we could point to, but in our work and in our theorizing, those are the main ones. Now, your study looked at perfectionism in college students, but is it also increasing in other age groups? And you talked about parents kind of leading the way. Are they themselves perfectionists, or they're just foisting this on their kids? A bit of both. Parental perfectionism is very strongly correlated with child perfectionism. We have to be a bit careful there because disaggregating what is social modeling from genes is a tricky one. If we know about 30 to 40% of perfectionism is inherited,
关于我们应该看起来、表现得如何的形象时，这肯定没有帮助。我们可以指出很多因素，但在我们的工作和理论中，这些是主要的因素。现在，你的研究关注的是大学生的完美主义，但它在其他年龄段也在增加吗？你谈到父母在某种程度上起到了带头作用。他们自己是完美主义者，还是他们只是把这种压力强加给孩子？两者兼而有之。父母的完美主义与孩子的完美主义高度相关。我们必须小心，因为将社会模仿与基因区分开来是一件棘手的事情。如果我们知道30%到40%的完美主义是遗传的，
so a lot of it is genetic. But beyond that, there will be parent socialization that is at play. And there are many different pathways in which parents can transmit perfectionism to young people through expectations, as I've talked about, but also through something called conditional regard. So there's conditionality of approval that can occur within parents that teachers children that only would have worth something when they've achieved
所以很大一部分是遗传的。但除此之外，还有父母的社会化在起作用。父母可以通过多种途径将完美主义传递给年轻人，通过我谈到的期望，也通过一种叫做“有条件关注”的东西。所以父母之间可能会出现认可的条件性，这教会孩子只有在他们取得成就时才是有价值的，
or done something well. And so conditional regard is a big one. There's also anxious forms of rearing that come into play as well. And children see parents behaving anxiously or fearing failure or treating mistakes of failure as big deals, as big problems. That's children themselves are those things are big problems
或者做得很好。所以有条件关注是一个大问题。还有焦虑的教养方式也在起作用。孩子们看到父母表现得焦虑，或者害怕失败，或者把错误视为失败，视为大问题，视为大麻烦。孩子们自己也会认为这些事情是大问题，
and they want to avoid them. So there's all sorts of different pathways through which parents can impact on affectionism. But it is also important to remember. remember that it is highly duty to. Have you been able to follow college students over time? So when they leave school and they go into the workplace, do they continue to have that perfectionism? Yes, they do.
他们想避免它们。所以父母可以通过各种不同的途径影响完美主义。但记住这一点也很重要。记住它在很大程度上是遗传的。你们能够长期跟踪大学生吗？所以当他们离开学校进入职场时，他们是否继续保持那种完美主义？是的，他们会。
There's not much life course analysis when it comes to perfectionism. So it's very difficult to say whether this is something that ameliorates or doesn't ameliorate over time. We know neuroticism does ameliorate over time. And so there may be an argument that that's the same for perfectionism. We need to test that. There was a couple of studies that show perfectionism can perhaps be a little stickier than neuroticism. One study shows that it's perfectionism and perfectionistic irritability seems to be quite sticky across the lifespan,
关于完美主义的生命历程分析并不多。所以很难说这是否是随着时间的推移而改善或不改善的事情。我们知道神经质确实会随着时间的推移而改善。所以可能有一种论点认为完美主义也是如此。我们需要测试这一点。有几项研究表明，完美主义可能比神经质更顽固。一项研究表明，完美主义和完美主义易怒性在整个生命周期中似乎相当顽固，
but that's an isolated study. We need to do more there. So it may be the case that perfectionism is a little bit more of a stable construct over time than something like neuroticism, or maybe it isn't. We just don't know. What role do you think that this increase in perfectionism and in the achievement culture is playing in driving the youth mental health crisis? Well, it's not the whole picture, of course. We are very keen to highlight perfectionism as a public health concern. We think that these are trends that are telling us something about the way young people are perceiving themselves, are viewing themselves in relation to other people, the way that they're perceiving the social environment.
但这是一项孤立的研究。我们需要在这方面做更多的工作。所以完美主义可能比神经质等特质在时间上更稳定，或者可能不是。我们只是不知道。你认为这种完美主义的增加和成就文化在推动青年心理健康危机中扮演了什么角色？嗯，当然，这并不是全部。我们非常热衷于将完美主义强调为一个公共卫生问题。我们认为这些趋势告诉我们年轻人如何看待自己，如何看待自己与他人的关系，如何看待社会环境，
and how demanding it is and what is expected of them. We think these are very salient trends in those respects. And because perfectionism, particularly socially prescribed perfectionist, has such a strong correlation with depression, anxiety, self-presentational concerns, and other psychologists, when I say big correlation, me for psychology research, you know, big correlations, we're talking about around 25% variance explained, depression and anxiety. You know, that's a lot when it comes to psychology research.
以及它有多苛求，对他们有什么期望。我们认为这些在这些方面是非常显著的趋势。而且因为完美主义，特别是社会规定型完美主义，与抑郁、焦虑、自我呈现担忧有很强的相关性，作为心理学家，当我提到“大相关性”时，对于心理学研究来说，你知道，大相关性，我们谈论的是大约25%的方差解释，抑郁和焦虑。你知道，在心理学研究中，这已经很多了。
because they share such a large correlation, we do think that perfectionism might be a part of the youth mental health crisis that we're currently seeing, not the only part, but certainly a part. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost.
因为它们有如此大的相关性，我们确实认为完美主义可能是我们目前看到的青年心理健康危机的一部分，不是唯一的部分，但肯定是一部分。你说这个地方离水只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够迷路了。
Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room, just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is. on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. When we think about stereotypes of achievement culture, like the pressure to get perfect grades and in the U.S., these high SAT scores, you know, to get into college or participating in the right extracurricular activities, it feels like something that applies mostly to the top end of the
或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房，距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在Hilton.com或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可节省20%，获得您预期的住宿体验。当您想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。您住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，为您提供住宿。当我们想到成就文化的刻板印象时，比如获得完美成绩的压力，在美国，这些高SAT分数，你知道，为了进入大学或参加正确的课外活动，感觉这似乎主要适用于
socioeconomic ladder. Is that correct or is this tendency cutting across the socioeconomic spectrum? Now, that would be correct to say. And Dr. Lufa has published some incredibly important research on this topic showing that the more affluent teens are actually those that disproportionately suffer in terms of their mental health from the achievement pressures that they experience at school because they're the ones that are most aggressively primed for elite college and they experience a lot of psychological difficulties, substance abuse issues, and behavioural issues, a lot of which is actually not as documented, I think, as perhaps it should be, because we quite rightly focus on the more deprived end of the socio-economic
社会经济阶梯的顶端。这是正确的吗，还是这种倾向跨越了社会经济光谱？现在，这样说是不准确的。卢法（Lufa）博士在这个主题上发表了一些非常重要的研究，表明越富裕的青少年实际上在心理健康方面受到的成就压力影响越大，因为他们是被最积极地推向精英大学的人，他们经历了许多心理困难、药物滥用问题和行为问题，我认为其中很多实际上并没有像应该的那样被记录下来，因为我们理所当然地关注社会经济光谱中更贫困的一端，
spectrum, absolutely we do because there's a lot of suffering there for many, many reasons, but also at the same time, I think it's important for us to highlight that there are teens at the higher-end of social spectrum inspection who are suffering from an excessive need to achieve so much pressure they're putting on themselves, partly rooted in perfectionism, but having impacts more broadly on their mental health. Is the educational system itself contributing to this? I mean, I know kids today come home with hours of homework. When I was a kid, you know, maybe I had a half an hour or max an hour worth of homework every night.
绝对是的，因为由于许多许多原因，那里有很多痛苦，但同时，我认为强调社会经济光谱高端的青少年也因为过度的成就需求而受苦，他们给自己施加了太大的压力，部分植根于完美主义，但对他们的心理健康产生了更广泛的影响，这一点很重要。教育系统本身是否对此有贡献？我的意思是，我知道现在的孩子每天带着几个小时的家庭作业回家。当我还是个孩子的时候，你知道，我每晚可能只有半小时或最多一小时的家庭作业。
I don't know how kids do it today. It's an incredibly tough schooling process. I think on average there's about 130 standardized tests that young people will undertake from kindergarten to the 12th grade. I mean, that's an incredible amount of testing and ranking and sifting and sorting. And so you can only imagine the ways in which young people begin to construe a sense of self-in identity in those contexts, which is essentially self-identity that's pinned to how well we perform, where we sit in the rank.
我不知道现在的孩子是怎么做到的。这是一个极其艰难的学校教育过程。我认为平均而言，年轻人从幼儿园到12年级要参加大约130次标准化考试。我的意思是，这是难以置信的考试、排名、筛选和分类。所以你只能想象年轻人在这些背景下开始构建自我认同感的方式，这本质上是与我们表现如何、我们在排名中处于什么位置挂钩的自我认同。
And of course, that's a very fragile sense of self-worth because the moment things go wrong or the moment we get a bad test score, our self-esteem plummets and we start to experience a lot of rumination, shame, guilt, stress. There's no doubt that there's a lot of pressure in schooling. And I understand the need for standardized testing. Of course, there is a place for it. But I think what we have at the moment is an excessive cold.
当然，这是一种非常脆弱的自我价值感，因为一旦事情出错，或者一旦我们得到一个糟糕的考试成绩，我们的自尊心就会暴跌，我们开始经历大量的反刍、羞耻、内疚、压力。毫无疑问，学校教育中存在很大的压力。我理解标准化考试的必要性。当然，它有一席之地。但我认为我们目前拥有的是一种过度的崇拜，
which is standardised testing, which is creating a lot of worry, a lot of anxiety. Given your knowledge of all this, do you go easy on your students? Do you give fewer tests? I mean, I don't want to give them any tests if I can avoid it. I feel like they've done that enough at this point. But no, the way that I try to assess is really to emphasize feedback, to make sure that I, you know, especially in the first year, because in the UK system, the first year doesn't count anything as much. We're trying not to even give us a a grade. It's all about what was what was done well, what could be improved, and those things to focus on as you develop your understanding knowledge in a certain area. And, you know, that's
即标准化考试，这正在制造大量的担忧和焦虑。鉴于你对这一切的了解，你对你的学生放轻松吗？你给的考试更少吗？我的意思是，如果能避免，我不想给他们任何考试。我觉得他们到目前为止已经做得够多了。但不是，我尝试评估的方式确实是强调反馈，确保我，你知道，特别是在第一年，因为在英国体系中，第一年并不算什么。我们甚至尽量不给成绩。这一切都是关于做得好的地方，可以改进的地方，以及当你发展对某个领域的理解知识时要关注的事情。而且，你知道，这
difficult because it's really jarvis students to come into that different way of learning to not have a grade and to not have something. They can anchor their sense of self around, but ultimately it's a much healthier way to learn, I think. Is there such a thing as healthy perfectionism? I mean, can you be a perfectionist in a way that's not detrimental to your well-being? I'm going to say no. But this is a connection. contentious topic. And if you speak to other psychologists in the area, you may get different answers. It's all good fun, but it does hit on, I think, something really important.
很困难，因为学生们进入这种不同的学习方式，没有成绩，没有可以锚定自我感的东西，这确实让他们感到不安，但最终，我认为这是一种更健康的学习方式。有“健康的完美主义”这种东西吗？我的意思是，你能以一种不损害你幸福感的方式成为完美主义者吗？我会说不。但这是一种有争议的话题。如果你和该领域的其他心理学家交谈，你可能会得到不同的答案。这很有趣，但我认为它确实触及了一些非常重要的事情。
And that's the question of whether this is a construct that we need to find the positives in, or it's something that we need to find a completely different track to. And that there is nothing positive about perfection is going to need to step onto a different pathway. Even the high standards, excessive standards are themselves negative in my mind for two reasons. The first is because even if we do meet those high and excessive standards, the perfectionists can never enjoy them because there's always got to be something more. So we can't appreciate our successes even if we get them. And also, of course, those problems and things don't go quite so well for those high
那就是我们需要在其中找到积极因素，还是我们需要找到一条完全不同的轨道的问题。完美主义没有任何积极之处，需要踏上一条不同的道路。即使是高标准、过高的标准，在我看来也是负面的，原因有两个。第一个是，即使我们确实达到了那些高且过高的标准，完美主义者也永远无法享受它们，因为总会有更多的东西。所以即使我们成功了，我们也无法欣赏我们的成功。而且，当然，那些高且过高的标准完美主义者在事情进展不顺利时，
and excessive standard perfectionists because that's a big hit to their self-esteem. And so what they tend to do is avoid and divver and iterate and procrastinate to try to avoid those feelings of shame and guilt from making a mistake or hitting a setback. So that actually blocks our progress in the end. It doesn't carry us forward. And so for my mind, I think that the negatives far outweigh any positives that you might find from being a professionalism is much better to try to situate ourselves on a better track where we're focusing on our efforts.
这对他们的自尊心是一个巨大的打击。所以他们倾向于回避、拖延，试图避免因犯错或遇到挫折而产生的羞耻感和内疚感。所以这最终阻碍了我们的进步。它并没有推动我们前进。所以在我看来，我认为完美主义的负面影响远远超过了你可能从中发现的任何积极因素，最好尝试将自己置于一条更好的轨道上，我们专注于我们的努力。
We're focusing on the process of learning. We're trying to hit high goals, but we're maintaining the sense of perspective and that we're allowing ourselves to enjoy successes when they arrive. Those are all markers of a high achiever and it doesn't preclude high achievement by taking a slightly different track. But what it does mean is that we can enjoy the process. And as a consequence, we can find psychological well-being, purpose, and meaning through that process, which are things that we just simply can't do if perfectionism is in the driving scene. Part of your story is that you were a perfectionist.
我们专注于学习的过程。我们试图达到高目标，但我们保持一种视角，当我们取得成功时，我们允许自己享受它们。这些都是高成就者的标志，采取稍微不同的轨道并不会妨碍高成就。但它确实意味着我们可以享受这个过程。因此，我们可以通过这个过程找到心理健康、目标和意义，如果完美主义在驾驶座上，这些是我们根本无法做到的事情。你故事的一部分是你曾经是一个完美主义者。
Isn't that true? I mean, you recognize that in yourself and it kind of changed the way that you approach life. Can you talk about that a little bit? Yeah, a lot of people these days who are trying to climb the career ladder, affectionism really did take over in my own life, particularly in my early to mid-20s when I was doing, working all sorts of hours to try to lift myself above other people, to try and get as many publications out there as I could,
这不是真的吗？我的意思是，你认识到自己身上的这一点，它在某种程度上改变了你对待生活的方式。你能谈谈那个吗？是的，现在很多试图攀登职业阶梯的人，完美主义确实在我的生活中占据了主导地位，特别是在我20岁出头到30岁出头的时候，当时我正在做，工作各种各样的时间，试图把自己提升到其他人之上，试图尽可能多地发表文章，
to try and win as many grants as I could, to looking around at how other people are doing and using that as my benchmark for how good I should be doing. And, you know, there's an argument to suggest that it was part of why I'm here, but also it came at heavy cost. And I burnt out, I had to leave work for a number of months. It was a very difficult period in my personal life as well because it created all sorts of overflows in terms of the way in my relationships of other people. And so, you know, there was a lot of collateral. And although ostensibly I looked like I was a high achiever, underneath I was really sinking
试图赢得尽可能多的资助，观察其他人做得如何，并以此作为我应该做得多好的基准。而且，你知道，有一种论点认为这是我今天在这里的部分原因，但它也付出了沉重的代价。我精疲力竭了，我不得不离开工作几个月。这在我个人生活中也是一个非常困难的时期，因为它在我和他人的关系方式上造成了各种各样的溢出效应。所以，你知道，有很多附带损害。虽然表面上我看起来像是一个高成就者，但在内心深处，我真的在下沉，
and that was an impetus for me to take a different direction, choose a different track, to try to remove those narcissistic self-reference tendencies that I held within me, that contingent self-esteem I held within me based on my achievement and how I was appearing relative to other people and actually just try to be more centered and focus on what it is that I want to leave in the world, what it is I want to learn and I want to share. And that flicking that switch really helped me because it gave me a bigger purpose. It made me look more holistically, field. It made me want to ask bigger questions about what's happening at a societal level.
这促使我采取不同的方向，选择不同的轨道，试图消除我内心持有的那些自恋的自我参照倾向，我基于成就以及我相对于他人表现如何而持有的那种有条件的自尊，并实际上只是尝试更加中心化，专注于我想在世界上留下什么，我想学习什么，我想分享什么。拨动那个开关真的帮助了我，因为它给了我一个更大的目标。它让我看得更全面。它让我想要问关于社会层面正在发生什么的更大的问题。
And ultimately, that was the real reason why I think I'm here is because if I continued on that track, I'd have burnt out and I would be really struggling. But now I'm able to have good work-life balance and ask really interesting questions, which is one of the reason I'm talking to you, I suppose. Given that experience and also the research that you've done, do you have advice, you know, really specific advice for people who recognize the harmful perfectionist tendencies that they have and they want to change? What can they do? Well, there's loads of things to bear in mind. Again, that's also probably another book. But there's a few things that I found really useful in my experience and also to have some evidence behind them. The first is that self-compassion is a big part of combat imperfectionism.
最终，我认为我在这里的真正原因是因为如果我继续在那条轨道上，我会精疲力竭，我会非常挣扎。但现在我能够拥有良好的工作与生活平衡，并提出非常有趣的问题，我想这就是我跟你谈话的原因之一。鉴于那种经历以及你所做的研究，你有什么建议，你知道，真正具体的建议给那些认识到自己有有害的完美主义倾向并想要改变的人吗？他们能做什么？嗯，有很多事情要记住。同样，那可能也是另一本书。但我发现了一些在我的经验中非常有用的事情，而且它们背后也有一些证据。第一点是自我同情是克服完美主义的重要组成部分。
And self-compassion is really about recognizing that we are a fallible, exhaustible human being and that we're going to make mistakes that are going to hit setbacks. And that's just part and part of what it means to be human. And so recognizing that and actually internalizing that, that. And then making sure that we check in on ourselves when things go wrong and we go in on ourselves and maybe we're partially self-critical about how could it be so stupid. What are you thinking? And making sure we actively step in and intervene in those moments and find constructive and compassionate ways to move forward is really, really important. Because silencing that inner
自我同情确实是关于认识到我们是一个容易犯错、会精疲力竭的人类，我们会犯错，会遇到挫折。这只是作为人类的一部分。所以认识到这一点，并真正内化这一点。然后确保当事情出错时，我们检查自己，我们对自己进行反思，也许我们对自己如何能如此愚蠢进行部分自我批评。你在想什么？确保我们积极介入并干预那些时刻，找到建设性和富有同情心的方式前进是非常非常重要的。因为让那个内在的
critic is a big part of combating perfectionism. I think also, you know, on a work basis, one of the things I've found really useful is to try to prioritize. I put my priorities into buckets. There are things that require high level diligence. There are things that require the activities to be good enough. And then there are things that just need to get done. Not everything has to be done at 100 miles or not everything has to be done to the minute detail absolutely perfectly.
批评者沉默是克服完美主义的重要组成部分。我认为，在工作基础上，我发现非常有用的事情之一是尝试优先排序。我把我的优先级分成几个桶。有些事情需要高水平的勤奋。有些事情需要活动达到“足够好”。然后有些事情只需要完成。并不是每件事都必须以100英里的速度完成，或者每件事都必须完美到每一个细节。
Maybe some things require a little bit of conscientiousness, but actually most things know what I've got done and to be an efficient worker with that prioritize efficiently too. And we have to recognize that there are some tasks where good enough is. is good enough and actually making progress is more important than getting things absolutely perfect first time round. So it definitely helped me in terms of prioritising and putting my tasks into buckets and allowing myself, giving myself permission for things not quite to be
也许有些事情需要一点尽责，但实际上大多数事情知道我完成了，并且是一个高效的工人，这也能有效地优先排序。我们必须认识到，有些任务“足够好”就是足够好了，实际上取得进展比第一次就把事情做得绝对完美更重要。所以这绝对在优先排序和把我的任务分成桶，并允许自己，给自己许可让事情不完全是
of a certain standard for tasks that don't need to be at that certain standard. And finally, I also like to journal. I think this is a lot of evidence for journaling for all sorts of psychological ailments, but particularly for perfectionism. Just writing down our fears can be so important because one of the things that blocks perfectionist people is the fear that things might go wrong.
某种标准，对于不需要达到那种标准的任务，这对我很有帮助。最后，我也喜欢写日记。我认为有很多证据支持写日记对各种心理疾病都有好处，但特别是对完美主义。写下我们的恐惧是非常重要的，因为阻碍完美主义者的一件事是担心事情可能会出错。
They catastrophes a lot. And so writing down your fears, like not ignoring them or suppressing them, but actually writing them down, what is it you worried about? What stopping you making progress in this moment? And write it down, I journal. And then ask yourself, what steps, practical steps can I put in place to avoid that worst case scenario happening? And then draw it through to its conclusion, if it were to have.
他们经常灾难化。所以写下你的恐惧，不是忽略它们或压制它们，而是真正写下来，你担心的是什么？此时此刻是什么阻止你取得进展？把它写下来，我写日记。然后问自己，我可以采取什么步骤，实际的步骤来避免最坏的情况发生？然后把它推导到结论，如果它真的发生了。
happen. So let's say it did happen. What can we do to bring ourselves back to square one, right? And just putting those fears under the microscope and putting practical ways forward in the case to avoid it in the first case, but then in the case of actually happening, how do we move ourselves back? It's a really, really good way to break down those fears and it allows us to have a road map to move forward and then we could just get on and do it without that fear holding us back. What about parents and other caregivers? What can they do to encourage their kids while buffering them from the pressures that lead to perfectionism? I mean, you know you want your kid to get into the best school, but how can you keep your child from becoming overly anxious and suffering?
会发生什么。所以假设它确实发生了。我们能做些什么来让自己回到原点，对吧？把这些恐惧放在显微镜下，在第一种情况下采取实际的前进方式来避免它，但在实际发生的情况下，我们如何让自己回到原点？这是一种非常非常好的打破这些恐惧的方法，它让我们有了一个前进的路线图，然后我们就可以继续做下去，而不会让那种恐惧阻碍我们。父母和其他照顾者呢？他们能做些什么来鼓励他们的孩子，同时缓冲他们免受导致完美主义的压力？我的意思是，你知道你希望你的孩子进入最好的学校，但你如何防止你的孩子变得过度焦虑和受苦？
Yeah, there's a few things I would recommend to parents. First thing is don't put too much pressure on yourself because parenting is one of the hardest jobs. You can go into it the best intentions. and you can find very quickly that you're reduced to a helpless spectator. And that's just normal and natural and part of the process. So that I think is the first thing. Don't have but too much pressure on yourselves to get things just right. Winnicott's idea of the good enough parent is something that springs to mind when I think about parenting.
是的，我有几点建议给父母。第一件事是不要给自己施加太大的压力，因为育儿是最困难的工作之一。你可以带着最好的意图去做，但你会很快发现自己沦为一个无助的旁观者。这很正常，很自然，是过程的一部分。所以我认为这是第一件事。不要给自己施加太大的压力，要把事情做得恰到好处。当我想到育儿时，温尼科特（Winnicott）关于“足够好的父母”的想法浮现在脑海中。
You can't perfect. And that's good for kids because life is not perfectly. So a couple of practical things. Well, first of all, don't hitch your approval to achievement or, you know, how much effort kids are putting in, particularly when it comes to sports or academic activities. It's good to have standards. It's good to, you know, want children to do the best they can, but you have to be really careful as parents not to subtly qualify your approval based on the expectation that young people do more because it's very easy to slip into that trap when young
你不能完美。这对孩子有好处，因为生活并不完美。所以有几件实际的事情。首先，不要把你的认可与成就挂钩，或者，你知道，孩子们投入了多少努力，特别是在体育或学术活动方面。有标准是好的，你知道，希望孩子们尽他们所能是好的，但作为父母，你必须非常小心，不要根据年轻人做更多的期望来微妙地限定你的认可，因为当年轻人时，很容易陷入那个陷阱。
people have done, well, they've come home, they've got an A in their test, and and you go, that's great, okay, keep working, right? Because that full approval, full validation and recognition of parents is subtly withheld under the understanding of more. So essentially what we're doing is we're holding young people on tiptoes under the expectation they keep working. And that teaches them that they're only really worth something in this world if they strive and strive and strive and strive. And if they achieve and achieve and the moment they don't, then the implication is that other people will value them less. So conditional forms of acceptance are really problematic when it comes to development of perfectionism.
人们做到了，嗯，他们回家了，考试得了A，然后你会说，太棒了，好吧，继续努力，对吧？因为那种完全的赞许、完全的认可和肯定，在“更多”的理解下被微妙地克制了。所以本质上，我们所做的是让年轻人踮着脚尖，期待他们不断努力。这教会他们，只有在不断奋斗、奋斗、再奋斗的过程中，他们在这个世界上才真正有价值。如果他们不断取得成就，而一旦没有做到，那么言下之意就是别人会降低对他们的评价。因此，当涉及到完美主义的发展时，这种有条件的接受方式是非常成问题的。
So it's really important that you give your kids full unqualified approval when they've done well, but also when things haven't gone quite so well, you give them a hug, you tell them it's okay, it's just one test of many of the tests, right? It's not an indictment on you or your self-esteem. It doesn't say anything about whether your teacher likes you or whether you're good at this particular subject.
所以，非常重要的一点是，当孩子们做得好时，你要给予他们完全、无条件的赞许；但当事情进展得不那么顺利时，也要给他们一个拥抱，告诉他们没关系，这只是众多考试中的一次，对吧？这并不是对你本人或你自尊心的指责。这并不能说明你的老师是否喜欢你，或者你是否擅长这门学科。
It's just one test. And the most important thing is to immerse yourself in the learning process and things will turn around if you keep doing the revision and the reading and all the rest of it. I think it's really important to put around around our children in those moments and make sure that we give just as much acceptance when they've done well, when they haven't done quite sit well. And the second thing I would say is also just normalise mistakes, failures, setbacks. If you've had a bad day at work, it's okay to communicate that with young people. It's okay to sit around the dinner table and laugh about it. It lets them know that these things happen as past.
这只是一次考试。最重要的是让自己沉浸在学习过程中，如果你坚持复习、阅读以及做其他所有相关的事情，情况就会好转。我认为在这些时刻陪伴在孩子身边非常重要，并确保无论他们做得好还是做得不够好，我们都能给予同样的接纳。我要说的第二点是，要让错误、失败和挫折常态化。如果你在工作中度过了糟糕的一天，可以和年轻人交流。坐在餐桌旁谈笑风生也没关系。这让他们知道这些事情是现实生活的一部分，如果他们的父母能对此一笑置之，如果他们的父母能公开分享，那么这也给了他们这样做的许可。所以这是两个主要的方面，但正如我一开始所说，这真的非常非常难。对于所有的父母，你们做得很好。
of the real world and that if their parents can laugh about it, if their parents can share it openly, then that gives them permission to do it too. And so those are the two main ones, but as I said at the beginning, it's really, really hard. And to any parent out there, you're doing a great job.
我们能在社会层面做些什么来阻止这种完美主义的抬头吗？是的，我在书的最后一部分写到，社会可能需要做出改变，以减少压力，或者提供一个压力较小的环境，特别是对年轻人而言。我推荐了很多方法，虽然我认为未必都能实现，在某些方面甚至有些乌托邦色彩。但我确实认为，如果能实现，我们将看到压力减少，其中之一就是扩大
Is there something we can be doing on a societal level to stop this rise in perfectionism? Yes, and one of the things I write about the final part of the book is how society might need to change to, provide less pressure or provide a context of less pressure, particularly on young people. And there are many things that I've recommended, none of which I think are necessarily going to be implemented, but they're almost quite utopic in some ways. But I do think that if they were, we would see less pressure, one of which is an expansion
高等教育的参与度。事实上，大学扩大参与度是令人愤慨的，因为我们实际上只是在排除越来越多的孩子，随着大学竞争越来越激烈，这不是前进的方向。我们需要对教育进行大量投资。教育在社会层面有许多好处，不仅对年轻人，对整个社会也是如此。
of participation in higher education. I mean, it's scandalous, actually, the universities have an expanded participation, because all we're really doing is excluding more and more kids as colleges become more and more competitive and that's not the way forward. And it needs to be vast investment in education. Education has so many benefits at a societal level, not just for young people but society at large.
我们越是不增加大学的容量，竞争就会越激烈，年轻人获得入学机会的压力就会越大。所以我认为这是我们可以提供帮助的一件事。另一件事是，我认为在更广泛的层面上，我非常支持全民基本收入（UBI）。随着人工智能介入并占据大量生产力和工作岗位，我们很可能会看到全民基本收入的实施。
And the more that we don't increase the higher universities, the more that's going to become more competitive and the more pressure is going to be on young people to get to gain access. So I think that's one thing we could do to help. Another thing is, I think at a broader level, I'm a really big advocate of UBI. The universal basic income is something that we're probably going to see anyway as AI comes in to capture a lot of productivity and jobs.
我认为作为一种紧急措施，它将是必要的，以弥合当今世界与人工智能承担大部分我们过去所做工作的新世界之间的鸿沟。但我认为这将带来许多许多好处，特别是它将消除那种往往是完美主义导火索的匮乏感。这种认为如果我们冒险但没有回报就会陷入贫困的想法，带来了很多恐惧和担忧，
I think it's going to be needed as an emergency measure to bridge the gap between that world now and the new world where AI does a lot of the work that we used to do. But I think that will have many, many benefits. and in particular it will take away the sort of scarcity that often is the fire for perfectionism. This idea that if we take a risk but it doesn't pay off that we're going to be destitute is a lot of fear, it's a lot of worries,
很多不安全感，这在社会层面造成了大量的完美主义。全民基本收入在左右两派中都得到了支持，因为它能够激发创造力、促进创新，并提供一种安全感，使我们能够尝试新事物并进行创新。如果没有它，它会扼杀创新，因为完美主义阻碍了我们。
a lot of precarity, and that creates a lot of perfectionism at a societal level. And UBI has been advocated across the board from left to right on its ability to spur creativity, to spur innovation, to give almost a safety in there that allows us to try new things and be innovative. And without it, it stifles that innovation because perfectionism holds us back.
我在书中还提倡其他一些事情，但我认为这是两个最重要的。那么你接下来要做什么？你在忙什么？你的下一本书是什么？目前，我打算休息一段时间，从过去一两年艰苦的工作中恢复过来。是的，我很喜欢写这本书。我很喜欢走出去。我很喜欢与人交流。我很喜欢谈论完美主义。这确实，确实，你知道，我做这件事的原因之一就是为了传播这个信息。但与此同时，这也相当令人疲惫。我现在有一个年轻的家庭，我认为是时候稍微换个节奏，把重心放在家庭上了。
And there are other things I advocate in the book, but I think those are the two big ones. So what's next for you? What are you working on? What's your next book? At the moment, I'm just going to take a little bit of time off to recover from what's been a grueling year or two. Yeah, I've loved writing the book. I've loved getting out there. I've loved speaking to people. I've loved talking about perfectionism. It's really, it's really, you know, one of the reasons I did it was to spread the message. But at the same time, it's quite exhausting as well. And I have a young family now and I think it's time for me to switch gears a little bit and focus on my family.
也许几年后，我会写另一本书。对于接下来要做什么，我有一些想法。但我想现在，我打算听从自己的建议，获得一点工作与生活的平衡。好的，柯伦博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。谈话非常棒。谢谢你的邀请。要阅读更多关于柯伦博士和其他心理学家关于完美主义的研究，请访问美国心理学会（APA）杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）的十月刊。
And then maybe in a few years time, I'll write another book. I have some ideas on what might come next. But I think for now, I'm just going to listen to my own advice and get a bit of work-life balance. Well, Dr. Curran, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been fantastic to talk. Thank you for having me. To read more about Dr. Curran's and other psychologist's research on perfectionism, visit the October issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology.
请访问 www.APA.org/monitor。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。对于那些想了解更多关于心理学和美国心理学会工作的人，你可以加入我们成为支持者。你不必是心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志，也就是我刚才提到的《心理学监测》，以及我们书籍和其他出版物的折扣。所以，如果心理学是你的热情所在，或者你只是想了解更多关于这门科学的知识，你可以通过访问 at.apa.org/speaking 成为支持者。
Go to www.APA.org backslash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. And for those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, which I just mentioned, the monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a.ap.org slash speaking.
那是 at.apa.org/speaking。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。感谢收听。
That's at. AT. APA.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening.
代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。你无法与太阳讲道理。相信我们，我们试过了。这个夏天，是时候让那个愤怒的火球静音了。哥伦比亚（Columbia）的 Omni-Shade 技术专为保护而设计，
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. You can't reason with the sun. Trust us. We've tried. This summer, it's time to put that angry ball of fire on mute. Columbia's Omni-Shade Technology is engineered to protect.
让你免受太阳刺眼光线的伤害，这些光线会灼伤并损害你的皮肤。太阳是无情的，但我们的装备也是。在 Columbia.com 升级你的夏天，花更多时间在户外，少花时间涂抹乳液。不客气。哥伦比亚，为一切而设计。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
you from the sun's harsh rays that can burn and damage your skin. The sun is relentless, but so is our gear. Level up your summer at Columbia.com to spend more time outside and less time slathering on allotion. You're welcome. Columbia, engineered for whatever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。